what is this movie again what's called
it's called a light okay is it whatever
supposed to be bad I don't know babe why
are they speaking French I don't I don't
know wait so why is he not going with
her okay even you realize that I'm
watching this at the same time that you
are yeah so why would I know that
is she gonna kill him nope nope wait why
does she just hide all that stuff
because she's secretly a clown
nothing serious Ari no just watch the
movie
sorry what maybe see the Derby oh wait
but for real no but for real you need to
like stop talking wait dude just odd but
for real though do you get a sense that
she's bad what's your take on it cor we
are thirty minutes in no we aren't
thirty minutes in no boy I was asleep
for like two minutes
he's not watching another Brad Pitt
movie or nothing this was all you first
off you never leave a Brad Pitt movie
unsatisfied prop up I'm naked I'm gonna
take your pillow abrupt
he's not even a character I don't even
want this part I don't like what's
happening tell me when it's over
tell me when the scene is over okay how
long do you do this for Excel this music
goes away the music listen someone's
gonna get shot music he used tell me
when it's over
please fast forward it know what happens
and I google it oh well okay you can't
watch it but you'll google it
well no dies put your hand up shot
there's not even characters they're
probably even computer-generated they
are still supposed to be people what you
that you like to watch it me no me no
you should open that up no put that back
in boots got thirsty hold on one sec
okay here hold on to that would be our
bag do anything yeah just the water okay
thanks babe okay pause it now pause it
now cuz I gotta pee okay you're gonna be
okay all right are you hungry
imma longer I want to snack I'm gonna
sec pause oh this sucks babe I'm sorry
can you pause it I gotta pee again
I gotta pee what do you want me to do
I'm sorry I gotta get you a diaper
go get me a type of my dick favor now I
got a gun when you get someone no no
puzzle no no dream oh my god I can't
watch and not have something to drink
that's give me the strength to not kill
him
is he gonna kill him I'm gonna kill you
why would I know that
all right focus me focus do you think he
really loves her what I'm wondering if
he actually is into her or not or what
are they gonna reveal did you I think
this is one of those where I'm asking
the questions that you don't know either
yup
[Music]